welcome to this video the highlights
video for the 13th round of the
candidates tournament yeah let's quickly
think about the tournament situation
before the last two rounds I'm under
sleeting the tournament obviously with
the plus free score 13 games lost none
so comfortably cruising basically the
closest followers is aronian is one
point behind with the plus one score
then we have a couple of players with
fifty percent the main point is the
tournament only would get interesting in
case of a loss by are not in this round
an unexplained black against skyrocket
and if Kaioken wins the game then the
whole tournament would open up
enormously in the last round because
then cockiness within striking distance
and would have the better tie break
while when case of Aronian winning in
round 13 today he also would even tie
the score with our non so this is the
important game for the tournament if
kayaking manages to win others could
actually overtake honored in case of a
non-playing a draw he said basically
yeah he's um he's through so um I'm
going for the highlights video I'm going
I'm starting with the other games and do
vicious game last so let's see what
happened i'm starting with sweden
Mammadyarov both players are basically
out of the race for the for the for the
top for the top place mean theoretically
speaking players on fifty percent level
musharraf could win two games are not
losing two but this seems very unlikely
okay here we got a night off the Bishop
e3 line for once not h3 one point of h3
what they had played many challenge
before the corset ctrl G for which we
should be three does not do so it's
quite logical that mamedyarov is going
for this
with nijah for one of the sharper
options for black they actually played
them somewhat will align with age for
here and it turned out that in this
position it's not so easy for wide to to
get any good coordination going without
playing 95 if you cannot cancel long
this just after Wayne and yeah what
actually do you play he went for 95
which also looks quite logical however
after the capture and 90 form we got
some trades going which really can be
hardly avoided so we had this and here
it's already clear that we have some
more simplifications coming up soon i
decided to can't go for for this end
game here which if we look at this of
course looks a bit more comfortable for
white he's got the better porn structure
but it's also clear that the black king
is very well centralized and always
keeps an eye on the porn or not g4 but
those pawns and wide can try to to to to
do something but it's even here there is
really not much not much going on the
black king is just protecting everything
the only thing that black guy needed to
watch out for is rook trades this is a
rope trade that he can't afford this
actually would still be a draw but if we
look at there was an earlier way let's
say here he of course shouldn't trade
this will led to her this would lead to
a delusion king and bone and game yeah
just mayara from
do that so yeah stayed within the rook
endgame and it was basically a shuffle
back and forth very easy draw actually
out of the opening for Mammadyarov I
guess both players some are not really
yeah well okay they can fight for prize
money but it's simply happening anyway
that with the good opening prep you you
will get this kind of positions where
not much is going on and it's there's
also no big point in risking a lot here
when you cannot qualify anymore so a
draw in this game quite an
understandable result okay let's go and
watch Kramnik two part of now the game
also not relevant anymore for the for
the top places as some chrome [ __ ] on
a minus one score very disappointing and
to pull off as well being on minus one
but it is of course the sort of a grudge
match we're both players want to win and
we got on the Moscow variation of the
semi Slav always a struggle between
whites good center and blacks bishop
pair we see that topalov has avoided the
only earlier night 97 move that covers a
5 so wyd can actually occupy the square
done by chrome neck he is obviously
planning after Knight to d7 to support
his night with their form going for a
big big clumpy in the center yeah c5
however was played to follow this
breaking up the center and quite quickly
we get this typical pawn structure in
the center of the so-called ram
formation where why it is a bit more
comfortable but but not much here we got
to a funny situation after queen bee
three here in fact black had the option
to play be five which it first looks a
bit weird because Queen a three attacks
rook and the
as Bishop takes p5 the funny point
though is after Queen D 8 and the
capture here black actually has a row
it's a it's a perpetual attack on the on
the Queen so black could play b5 it's
it's not not a bad move but concedes the
draw the pile of plate B 6 i'm not sure
if you wanted to avoid the draw it's
possible that you wanted to fight try to
win but how to tell okay well we
continue why does trine a bit on the
kingside advancing them but black you
are defended accurately all this is is
well played and not not to be criticized
after f5 this is an interesting spot we
now get a transposition to an end game
which f5 really it writes and white has
no a great way to avoid it in this
trades ok and now white took on f5 yeah
you cannot go here because of subutex
check losing the house so black must
take here and after this we got a very
sharp end game with the two night seven
against two bishops normally a bad deal
for the Knights but here they cooperate
well with the H porn and I'm very active
like I got something back on be to check
yeah I'm term here King f7 was a mistake
it's difficult to show the analysis in
this brief summary video this is now a
good position for white because dn.h
pawn are dangerous and especially check
here check I've got one further critical
position here exactly in this position
it it happened
um now first of all we need to point out
that the day after this move back Romney
to pull off should have taken on f5
which probably would have let would have
led to a draw still tonight takes King
f7 to g6 seems to be still okay he
played a rookie tomb and this term has a
big problem and this is 97 it turns out
that this bishop in a way is strapped
and can sometimes just be attacked by
the look on the eighth-ranked we see
that can after this moves it cannot
escape anywhere played before Luke takes
and b3 and here we come to really am and
really amazing spot in the game where
chronic could have relatively easily one
with the rook da check this is what you
played rock da check check was the
possibility i'm sure that yet of course
seen the moose um and this is quite
easily winning simply because okay the
King needs to move let's say here
they're pushing age 7 and well I'm just
promoting there is a not much else
happening here really can try that but
check here black has no meaningful check
and this king will be hunted down by by
White's forces just much more much more
attacking power what I think is he
thought that both moves win his Muslim
looks good but it has a serious drawback
to pull off now were captured but if he
would have played he took we took a real
long time no what is the clock doing
here it's
it's going up this is weird yeah the
clocks on I see I just thought that he
would he spend lots of time but he
didn't stretch very straight clock clock
display here yeah well if he if we look
at the pure move and King c7 was I was
drawing the game because after this
check check we have a situation where
this Bishop is supporting the pawn to
promote and this is in fact the draw
white now will give a series of checks
to him to end the game but the problem
was he took and you know it's it's
almost the same but the problem is after
be too and this check now look at this
is what happened now there is no direct
threat IAM because the bishop on d3 is
not not on the board anymore so after
this check to palo for resigned if you
know if he moves the king for example
i'm going here and be one is just
protected this is the big difference so
right near the end he could have saved
the game and made it wrong yeah well I
guess games between those two are always
some with such a high tension that they
simply make more mistakes than then
usual i believe from the first game in
round 6 was also an example for that by
Kramnik really a plata for his standards
very very weak game and it's a it's
mostly I guess explained by my nerves
and intention okay so this game a win
for chronic very maybe and very
important but certainly important for
him that he had beat his nemesis at
least once in this tournament so it is a
big failure to to be just on fifty
percent for his for his ambitions and
qualities as a player
okay so let's go to and rake in her own
yang here with the winner onian could
stay in striking distance to Anand but
of course it's not in his hands anymore
let's say if honored wins for example
it's over anyway but okay let's see what
happens and Drake in the scott white and
he's and wrecking his on a minus one
score so he's certainly I would assume
not not in any way unsatisfied with us
as Rosa with with his result ok 9 f 6
and verse 55 the Trump ASCII opening the
Trump rare guest at top level but
nevertheless quite a good opening and an
opening that Andre keen is playing
sometimes not all the time but sometimes
he is doing that he's played many of
those type of openings when he came
second in the World Cup last year so it
was to be expected in a way aronia know
I have applied g6 after three minutes
which is a bit a bit puzzling and in
fact he played a real egg in my opinion
strange setup here combining all sorts
of pawn moves that at the end check HERE
led to position we can do this quickly
where black has many structural
weaknesses here everything's a bit weak
GM with this maneuver defended these
these weaknesses so it's what it's not
like black is in a terrible position but
it's simply not a great opening result
is especially considering that you might
in a way try to wear try to win the game
okay yeah we got to an end game here
where white has this pressure on b7
which in a way almost forces the the
sequence now black takes on c4 taking it
in exchange for the b7 porn check and we
come to an important position right now
f4 was needed to support b5
there should be three and King to be too
so it's an exchange sacrifice and here
I'm quite surprisingly Aronian didn't
take it I mean it's not entirely clear
cut I understand that but it seems that
it was a much better choice to to grab
the exchange and then Black has a choice
but my suggestion would be to play h5
during h4 try to open up the H file for
counter play this is dangerous of course
for black as well because there is
always this danger that maybe the apron
gets lost and then you have got to give
got two passes but this takes a while
and if white is doing that without
looking at the counter play by black
like age for Luke to h2 then it can get
very tricky and this sort seems to be a
defendable position to me he took on a
four and this now leads to leads to some
trouble check white keeps the beep horn
and it's so active that he will get the
apron back we got to this rook endgame
now and here black must be very very
precise to to defend it in fact only a
couple of moves later right here Aronian
took on f2 and it seems that I'm sorry
it seems that this move actually loses
the game after King c6 wide invades and
the King supports the beep on it seems
that he needed to stay on the C file and
play something like rook to be aid it's
still not very nice to defend the
position and I have my doubts that black
and defended in the long run but this is
a definite definite losing moose care
its wife now managed to enter with the
king and you can always block against
the checks from the back which anyone
looks can some repetitions here chapter
after chapel of moves check yeah we come
to the position where this pawn will
promote like rookie a Jew k
and white will promote them all upon to
be Pawnee so another disappointing
result for huronian who simply seems to
not play at his best in this candidates
tournaments of course it was probably
already too late by this stage but
losing three games over 13 games
assembly is simply too much to to win
this kind of event even losing two games
seems quite a lot but three years just
too much so it's back on fifty percent
and under akin also on fifty percent
which means that our own ian is also out
of the picture to to catch on and at all
no matter what Arnold is doing in this
round this is the game that we still
need to look at kayaking Anand let's
pull this let's click on this year and
start the start them brief analysis of
this game so now that we know there are
the results it's very clear-cut if Anand
drawers or wins he is the Challenger
form Council if he loses then kayaking
can catch him and only kayak and can
catch him so I'm pretty clear outline
for this game we got a Queens gambit one
of the numerous entire Berlin setups as
one could joke in this state because way
I can play see for as usual there might
be a balloon and not sure you want to
try to lock them they get a Queens
gambit with III as quiet line but a line
that keeps pieces on the board in yeah
then we had this earlier in the
tournament the game Kramnik aronia that
Aronian played b6 somewhat earlier in
fact and they got a really complicated
position and of course and it's not
looking for a very complicated position
here is playing a quick see five tries
to open up the center and maybe get some
simplifications and yeah white not took
on d5 and took on c5 you
to argue that this is maybe a bit team
but it's not clear that other
continuations did did more after Bishop
takes I think maybe why dumb has a
slight edge because this is really nice
piece but it's not much nevertheless I
not decided to do something out the
plate 97 with the idea to capture with
the night which would be very nice if
you if you manage to get this in so
kayaking decided to give up the porn in
this way giving black at least them
something to yeah something to look at
as a weakness on c6 here quickly
attacked this weakness with Quincy to
but Alan term was some playing her form
for complete clearance of the queenside
with a form yeah whiter now it took on
26 which is probably right Queen air
five plate here he had a good move with
Luke a five but it's a bit a bit of a
computer ish line the ideas to trap the
Queen after this capture and it
sometimes is possible in this in this
line here too I mean this is an idea
anyway it's sometimes possible to play
Bishop to be seven and Queen to a head
ok but this was played and this led to
simplifications wear black game at the
moment is two points down but we'll get
back one of them like this yeah so we
have trade trade down to an end game
white has the a pawn so not a bad
opening result for white and then a nerd
quickly needs to increase the pressure
against the pawn which you did the only
problem was that now there is lots of
pressure on c5 and you cannot really
retreat the night this is a bit too much
on the same rank so black has no big
choice here needs to take on take on a
two and after this we got by force to
this end game
after 26 moves we got to an end game
where white has bishop and night against
rook not for a porn even so it should be
theoretically speaking very good for
white it's a solid edge and it probably
is rightly assessed at being somewhat
better for white but the question is can
you actually win this position problem
is you would need to win one of those
pawns to get anywhere and it's totally
symmetrical black has no weakness and
what honor duty took a foothold in the
center was f6 and e5 and basically
stayed put here maybe it's maybe that
that kayak he needed to play f4 at some
point let's say here but he hesitated a
bit with f3 and honored rather quickly
afterwards put Anakin can advance a bit
more here snow just want to show that
pawn structure alternating we had the
straights and he went to play g5 himself
maybe really before kayaking needed to
do a form at some point to to make to
make some progress I am Not sure that in
this position now there is still
anything left to do he captured on G Phi
which makes some sense of course because
now you have two unprotected pawns and
is by unprotected by other points that
you can attack but it seems that if you
look at the cause of the game they
continued for a long while you see that
black always was able to defend the
pawns it's a bit tricky now to show in
this summary video I tried tried a bit
in the the longer version of it but it
seems that there is simply no way to to
get don't get anywhere as wide I can
give a sort of fast-forward TM check
there was lots of shuffling going on
we came to the point where I'll not
actually push this age 13 check let's do
that check yeah as mentioned it took a
while check ya hear the age porn was the
final bullet that like a black and shoot
and use this as a source of counter play
and around here it became apparent that
there really is nothing left to do Black
is just too active with the rook and the
h-bomb white cannot really break through
here in this position you even cannot
move the bishop away sh1 is always
hanging so it's a draw for regime and he
threw facing Carlton again near the end
of the year the the venue is not set yet
they have them they have a bidding
process it seems you never know with
feeder maybe they pull something out of
their heads and they suddenly play in
the window and arctica or something you
never know what might are going to
happen okay so I know that vishy anand
is not watching this video but still I'm
sending out congratulations to him for a
fantastic effort really I mean
absolutely i really think that if you
would have asked like 100 chess players
and I mean besides maybe some some
people from India big fans of machine no
one would have thought that he would
have been able to pull this off even I
mean also doing it in such a very
convincing manner winning three games
losing none and being completely
completely in control in in almost all
of the games this is the only game where
he really was in some sort of trouble
and it was not like easily a parent our
how he could have could have lost here
in the same game it was certainly not
comfortable it um not to like you know
some easy wins in there okay I'll do a
summary or let's say a bit of a
like on a player for each player do a
quick summary of the tournament in the
in the final video for 114 so I'll leave
it at that I hope you enjoyed the
summary and of course as usual Dow the
single game videos to to dig a bit
deeper into some details thanks for
watching